we now move to the case of continuous
random variables we will start with a
special case where we want to find the
PDF of a linear function of a continuous
random variable we will start by
considering a simple example and study
it using an intuitive argument and
afterwards we will justify our
conclusions mathematically so we start
with a random variable X that has a PDF
over the form shown in this figure so
that it is a piecewise constant PDF we
then consider a random variable Z which
is defined to be 2 times X the random
variable X takes values between minus 1
and 1 so Z takes values between minus 2
and 2 now values of X between minus 1
and 0 correspond to values of Z between
minus 2 and 0 the different values of x
in this range are in some sense equally
likely because we have a constant PDF
and that argues that the corresponding
values of Z should also be in some sense
equally likely so the PDF should be
constant over this range by a similar
argument the PDF of Z should also be
constant over the range from 0 to 2 and
the PDF must of course be 0 outside this
range because these are values of Z that
are impossible let us now try to figure
out the parameters of this PDF the
probability that X is positive is the
area of this rectangle and the area of
this rectangle is 2/3 so the area of
this rectangle should also be 2/3 and
that means that the height of this
rectangle should be equal to 1/3
similarly the probability that X is
negative is the area of this rectangle
and the area of this rectangle is equal
to 1/3 when X is negative z is also
negative so the probability of negative
values should be equal to 1
and for the area of this rectangle to be
1/3 it means that the height of this
rectangle should be 1/6 so what happened
here we started with a PDF of X and
essentially stretched it out by a factor
of 2 while keeping the same shape
however we also scaled it down by a
corresponding amount so 2/3 became 1/3
and 1/3 became 1/6 the reason for this
scaling down is because we need the
total probability the total area under
this PDF to be equal to 1 if we now add
a number let's say 3 to the random
variable Z what is going to happen the
random variable Y now will take values
from minus 2 plus 3 this is plus 1 all
the way up to 2 plus 3 which is plus 5
values in the range from 1 to 3
correspond to values of Z in the range
from minus 2 to 0 these values are all
in some sense equally likely so they
should also be equally likely here and
by a similar argument these values in
the range from 3 to 5 should also be
equally likely this rectangle
corresponds to this rectangle here so
the area should be the same and
therefore the height should also be the
same
therefore the height here should be 1/6
and by the same argument the height here
should be equal to 1/3 so what happens
here is that when we add 3 to a random
variable the PDF just gets shifted by 3
but otherwise retains the same shape so
the story is entirely similar to what
happened in the discrete case we start
with a PDF of X we stretch it
horizontally by a factor of 2 and then
we shift it horizontally by 3
only difference is that here in the
continuous case we also need to scale
the plot in the vertical dimension by a
factor of two actually make it smaller
by a factor of two and this needs to be
done in order to keep the total area
under the PDF equal to one let us now go
through a mathematical argument with the
purpose of also finding a formula that
represents what we just did in our
previous example let Y be equal to ax
plus B here X is a random variable with
a given PDF a and B are given constants
now if a is equal to zero then Y is
identically equal to B so it is a
constant random variable and does not
have a PDF so let us exclude this case
and start by assuming that a is a
positive number we can try to work as in
the discrete case and try it something
like the following the probability that
Y takes on a specific value is the same
as the probability that a X plus B takes
on a specific value which is the same as
the probability that X takes on the
specific value y minus B divided by a
this equality was useful in the discrete
case is it useful here unfortunately not
when we're dealing with continuous
random variables the probability that
the continuous random variable is
exactly equal to a given number this
probability is going to be equal to zero
and the same applies to this side as
well so we have that zero is equal to
zero and this is an informative and we
have not made any progress so instead of
working with probabilities of individual
points which will always be 0
we will work with probabilities of
intervals that generally have nonzero
probability the trick is to work with
CDF so let us try to find the CDF of Y
the CDF of the random variable Y is
defined as the probability that the
random very
is less than or equal to a certain
number now in our case why is ax plus B
we move B to the other side of the
inequality and then divide both sides of
the inequality by a and we get that this
is the same as the probability that X is
less than or equal to Y minus B divided
by a which is the same as the CDF of X
evaluated at y minus B over a so we have
a formula for the CDF of Y in terms of
the CDF of X how can we find the PDF
simply by differentiating we
differentiate both sides of this
equation the derivative of a CDF is a
PDF and therefore the PDF of Y is going
to be equal to the derivative of this
side here we need to use the chain rule
first we take the derivative of this
function and the derivative of the CDF
is a PDF so the PDF of X evaluated at
this particular number but then we also
need to take the derivative of the
argument inside with respect to Y and
that derivative is equal to 1 over a and
this gives us a formula for the PDF of Y
in terms of the PDF of X how about the
case where a is less than 0 what is
going to change the first step up to
here remains valid but now when we
divide both sides of the inequality by a
the direction of the inequality gets
reversed so we obtain instead the
probability that X is larger than or
equal to Y minus B divided by a and this
is 1 minus the probability that
X is less than Y minus B over a now X is
a continuous random variable so the
probability is not going to change if
here we make the inequality to be a less
than or equal sign and what we have here
is 1 minus the CDF of X evaluated at Y
minus B over a we use the chain rule
once more and we obtain that the PDF of
Y in this case is equal to minus the PDF
of X evaluated to Y minus B over a times
1 over a now when a is positive a is the
same as the absolute value of a when a
is negative and we have this formula we
have here a minus a which is the same as
the absolute value of a so we can unify
these two formulas by replacing the
occurrences of a and that minus sign by
just using the absolute value and this
gives us this formula for the PDF of Y
in terms of the PDF of X and it is a
formula that's valid whether a is
positive or negative what this formula
represents is the following because of
the factor of a that we have here we
take the PDF of X and scale it
horizontally by a factor of a because of
the term B that we have here the PDF
also gets shifted horizontally by B and
finally this term here corresponds to a
vertical scaling of the plot that we
have and the reason that this term is
present is so that the PDF of Y
integrates to 1 it is interesting to
also compare with the corresponding
discrete formula that we derived earlier
the discrete formula has exactly the
same
appearance except that the scaling
factor is not present so for the case of
continuous random variables we need to
scale vertically the PDF but in the
discrete case such as scaling is not
present